good morning it's seven o'clock you're
watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster boris johnson will
be rolling up his sleeves to receive his
first cover jab today
but has he done enough to allay concerns
about an expected shortage of the
astrazeneca vaccine next month
and could coronavirus certificates be
the key to allowing us to return on mass
to sporting events and concerts this
summer
the culture secretary oliver dowden
seems to think so he'll be joining us
shortly also this morning
blooming marvellous with more of us
enjoying outdoor spaces in lockdown
we'll talk to the national trust about
their initiative to get people snapping
the spring blooms
and let's have it large a music marathon
for the mind we'll speak to the dj who's
going to be raising money
the mental health charities with a
40-hour set
starting from tonight it's friday the
19th of march
under pressure but standing firm nicola
sturgeon criticizes a leaked report
which says she misled the scottish
parliament
what's been clear is the opposition
members of this
committee made their minds up about me
before i uttered a single
word of evidence she has reached the
men's studio code
on numerous occasions she cannot
continue you cannot continue
with that doubt of trust
also this morning a new study suggests
vaccinations alone are unlikely to
contain covert infections in the uk
as the prime minister prepares to have
his job later today
a raft of european countries to resume
the astrazeneca rollout
as 16 regions of france prepare to go
back
into lockdown workplace warnings
calls for more support for vocational
students as job prospects suffer
due to the pandemic making waves with
whales the sound monitoring devices
aimed at preventing the marine mammals
from being struck
by large vessels and a fair amount of
cloud around for today with some drizzle
but
some places will see blue skies and
sunshine as well so a little bit of
everything in the forecast
i'll have the details for you later in
the programme
good morning nicolas sturgeon has
criticized a leaked report which found
that she misled the scottish parliament
sky news understands that hollywood's
harassment committee has reached the
conclusion
by a majority vote ahead of the
publication of its final report
the first minister says she stands by
the evidence she gave
but her opponents are calling for her
resignation our scotland correspondent
james matthews reports
this was nicola sturgeon last night
having just heard the verdict from
hollywood
that she its first minister had misled
parliament
this was her first reaction well
i think the first thing to say is i
stand by all of the
evidence i gave to the committee all
eight hours worth of
evidence i mean what's been clear is the
opposition members of
this committee made their minds up about
me before i uttered a single
word of evidence their public comments
have made that clear so this
leak from the committee very partisan
leak
tonight before they've actually
finalized the report is
not that surprising from the court of a
parliamentary committee
the verdict was by majority against its
first minister
it concluded that she misled them about
a meeting with alex salmon three years
ago that i will tell the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth when she said that she hadn't
offered to intervene
in a government investigation into
complaints against him
they'd met along with his legal adviser
duncan hamilton
from the minute i saw the letter i knew
that it would not be appropriate for me
to intervene
i probably was trying to you know soften
that
for him maybe from his accounts i
softened that
too much the committee agreed
taking account of the competing versions
of the event the committee believes that
she did in fact leave alex almond
with the impression that she would if
necessary intervene
this is confirmed by duncan hamilton who
was also at the meeting
her written evidence is therefore an
inaccurate account
of what happened and she has misled the
committee on this matter
this is a potential breach of the
ministerial code
under the terms of section 1.3 c
i don't want to prejudice the
publication of the inquiry report but if
there is a misleading of the inquiry
that is extremely serious
and if the hamilton inquiry finds
breaches of the ministerial code
based on principle takeout personality
takeout party
the minister should resign according to
the ministerial code
ministers who knowingly mislead
parliament are expected to resign
holy's harassment committee didn't use
the word knowingly
when it concluded that nicola sturgeon
had misled them that may yet be a
significant factor
as she faces down calls for her
resignation
we need to have faith that the first
minister is truthful
and if it is the case that the first
minister has misled parliament
as we believe she has and she has
reached the ministerial code on numerous
occasions she cannot continue
this hollywood inquiry committee will
deliver its full report next week
it isn't the only one that's looked at
whether nicola sturgeon broke the
ministerial code
there's another one in tandem that rose
out of the controversy
surrounding the alex salmond affair
let's wait and see what the final
reports have to say amidst talk of a
potential resignation matter
on its conclusions hinge a matter of
resignation
james matthews sky news edinburgh
now could so-called covid certificates
be the key to life getting back to
normal
the culture secretary oliver dowden
seems to think so hoping the likes of
wembley stadium
can be filled again with fans for the
euro championships this summer
i can speak to mr dowden now good
morning to you uh we'll come to that in
a moment but i wonder first you can
comment
on our top story and that the calls for
the leader of the scottish are
conservatives that nicholas sturgeon
should leave now do you agree
with those calls well of course i
support our leader in scotland and
we're uh clearly awaiting the full
committee uh report but i think douglas
ross has set out that position very
clearly yes
but you don't feel able to to comment on
whether she should resign now
bearing in mind that it has been found
that she misled parliament well
let's wait for the the full committee uh
reports to be
uh published and uh douglas ross as our
leader in scotland will be uh responding
uh to that uh in the the appropriate way
i think really the
the choice facing people in in scotland
in these elections is
do we get on and deal with covid and the
recovery or do we get stuck
in yet more years of constitutional
wrangling which we
thought we'd dealt with um at the time
of the scottish referendum back
in 2014. okay let's look at your brief
now how are plans uh shaping up for
people being able to attend live events
in the summer well we've set out a
really ambitious
roadmap which we're working very hard to
deliver on
so uh it all goes well and vaccine
remains on track as it is
and we keep the disease under control by
the 17th of may we'll be back to the
sort of things that we saw
last summer so socially distance
performances
uh indoor and outdoor and then the big
step four will be on the 21st of june
which mean which will be the point at
which we want to get as much back as we
possibly can and i'm working really
intensively
to work on the safest way to do that so
i've already announced
a pilot for example we're going to pilot
at the
fa cup final we're going to pilot at the
crucible
we're looking at how we can ensure in
indoor
and outdoor settings how we can get as
many people back
as we possibly can and get back to the
things we we really love as a nation
uh your quotas and papers today are
saying that you're confident fans can
pour into wembley with less or
no social distancing for the euros and
that's because of covert
certification what what exactly will be
covert certificates and what will that
entail
well um from the 21st of june if it all
goes uh to plan in the way that i
described we hope to get
people back in significant numbers we're
piloting the different things that will
enable that to happen clearly it will
have to be done in a covered secure way
so you would
expect we'll be testing these things
things like one-way systems
things like masks things like hand
hygiene and everything else and as part
of that
another thing that we are considering is
a covid certification and we'll be
testing whether we can use covert
certification
to help uh facilitate the return of
sports obviously final decisions have
not been taken on that and i'm working
with chancellor duchy of lancaster
michael gove who is leading on our
covert certification
work program but i think that is a
potential tool that could help
the return of or of the things that we
love
but but what exactly will a covid
certificate be in and how will that
differ from a vaccine passport say i
mean people will want to know
the manuscript of what a certificate
will mean
yeah and we are um we are working
through those details and we've already
said that
we've got to review that review as
ongoing and we'll publish the review
we've been clear
that there won't be a vaccine uh
passport the prime minister has
made that very clear what we have said
though is that in order to
to prove uh for example that you've um
had a vaccine or that you've had a
successful negative test
we'll we're looking at ways to help
facilitate proving that
and that may be one of the things that
could help ensure that we can get more
people
back into stadiums but remember there's
there's sort of there's three tracks
going on here at the
the same time one and the most important
thing of all
is that we continue to control this
disease so that means everyone
abiding by the rules it's working
getting numbers down and the
risks taking their vaccine when they get
the call up to do so we're making good
progress on that
secondly uh the chance of the duchy of
lancaster
and others i'm i'm helping alongside
this is looking at different mitigations
that we could use including the
the covered vaccine uh certification
and i'm also through my how would
somebody go about
getting a covid certificate how long
would it last
and and how would you police that they
have actually gone through the right
process to get the certificate
yeah and look those are all entirely
legitimate questions which is exactly
why we have set up
this review and we're working through
the challenges to get that right and
what we said is that can potentially be
a tool that will enable people
to return but remember it will sit
alongside other things to make places
uh safe like one-way systems like hand
sanitizing
and all of this is all predicated on
getting the
the vaccine roll out delivered and
getting the disease under control
because it's only if we do those things
that we can even start considering
the kind of large numbers of people
returning that we so desperately want
from the 21st of june which
i'm making my my number one mission i've
been meeting uh
several times this week that's why we've
got nick heitner
a very famous theater producer david
ross working with
many many people to see how we can get
people back
safely in large numbers because if we
don't manage to do it if we don't manage
to do it this summer
if we succeed with a vaccine roll out if
we succeed in getting the disease under
control
i'm really worried about the future of
those uh
industries are so vital not just to our
sense of national well-being
but to the whole national economy and do
you envisage that there still will be
social distancing you're saying that you
want to get the maximum people back into
stadia but
will there be social distancing well i i
hope we will be able to find ways of
mitigating against certainly having the
sort of social distancing that we have
at the moment because the sort of social
distancing we have at the moment
makes it very very difficult for example
for
uh theater productions to be run
profitably it makes it very very
difficult for
our football clubs to um to run
profitably if you have to have those
large distances between people
now clearly we've been in the situation
for the past year we've had to have
those distances
so we are proceeding with caution that's
why it's the last stage
that's why we are piloting different
ways of mitigating against that
and as we've discussed one of the things
that we are considering as part of that
is coping certification
and can you guarantee once open football
stadium and the like will be
able to remain open we have heard from
the scientists that when it comes to the
the winter months we might have to start
wearing masks again
and then by implication social
distancing again
well that's why we are proceeding with
caution because we really want these to
be
a permanent uh re-openings and one of
the things that i know that
frustrated people uh last year
was not being able to have that that
sort of certainty
obviously as as you and your viewers
will appreciate
this terrible disease um has
uh changed over time but we will be
we'll be doing everything we can to
ensure that it's permanent i'm sure
you'll
appreciate that we can't foresee every
um last eventuality but
what we are doing is trying to get the
conditions right so this this will be a
permanent
reopening um i wonder what you make of
the university of warwick's
modeling study that's out today in which
they say it's
vaccinating all adults in the uk is
unlikely
to achieve herd immunity and fully
contain the virus
well first of all vaccination has a huge
beneficial
impact it has a huge a beneficial impact
for the
people taking it it's the best way to to
stop you uh getting the disease and once
you've had two doses it is
highly effective and certainly if we as
we get through
the the top uh nine categories and we're
confident we'll do that by
mid-april we should see enormous
reductions in hospitalizations
and deaths
specifically on their line that it won't
fully contain the virus
um well the the evidence is emerging on
the effect of the vaccine
on spread so we we don't know fully the
picture i think it will have a
significant effect on spread but no
vaccine is going to be perfect of course
not you're not you're not going to
by vaccine alone uh fully prevent
the spread of the disease but the the
sort of steps that we have
outlined have in mind that we
sufficiently reduce hospitalizations
uh reduce deaths so that we can live
with this disease
over the coming years so there won't be
an elimination of the
disease but we should get to a point
where it is safe for most activities
to resume and that is what the roadmap
is all about
and on the vaccines on the shortage can
you clarify exactly what the situation
is with the
the lack of vaccines that are coming
from india
uh well i i think the prime minister and
the chief medical officer and health
secretary
addressed this yesterday there has been
a uh delay
uh in respect for about five million
doses from the the serum uh institute in
india they are
doing a fantastic job and working as
hard as they can we always knew there
were going to be
a fluctuations in the vaccine but we are
confident on those landmarks to
reopening
that we are on the right track so we got
the most at risk people
vaccinated uh by the middle of february
by the middle of april we want to get
all over 50s and the most vulnerable
and vaccinated we're confident we're on
course that once we've done that we
really will have a huge impact on
reducing deaths and hospitalizations and
then by the end of
uh july we're still on track for getting
the rest of the adult population uh
vaccinated so
you would expect movements up and down a
bit but the overall trajectory
we're very much on course with that
oliver dad and cultural secretary thank
you very much for speaking to us this
morning
thank you still to come
on the show following three shootings in
atlanta
georgia this week and a rise in hate
crime against asian people
we speak to the chair of end the virus
of hate from utam at quarter to eight
at five past eight we'll discuss the
latest on the potential shortage of
vaccines with imperial college london's
vaccine lead professor
robin shattuck and with more of us
enjoying outdoor spaces in lockdown
we'll talk to the national trust about
their initiative to get people
snapping for spring blooms that's at 20
past eight
france italy and germany are beginning
to roll out the oxford astrazeneca jab
again today
after they reversed their decision to
temporarily pause its use over blood
clot concerns
with the european medicines agency
confirming the vaccine is safe
and effective it comes as cases continue
to rise across the continent in france
16 areas including
the capital paris have entered new
lockdown restrictions
non-essential shops will close and
inter-regional travel will be
prohibited but schools will remain open
meanwhile new research in the lancet
suggests vaccination alone is unlikely
to contain
coronavirus infections in the uk but
gradual reopening and
high vaccine uptake could minimize
future waves
when it comes as the prime minister
boris johnson will have his first dose
of oxford astrazeneca vaccine this
afternoon
as he continues to try and reassure
people the jab
is safe and our political correspondent
as you can see rob powell is uh
with me now and rob um how is the the
prime minister doing in that job of
of reassuring people that astrazeneca is
safe and also that the glitch in supply
isn't really going to have an adverse
effect
yeah there has been these two issues
isn't there over the last week over
safety and supply i think on safety we
heard from the chief
medical officer chris witte yesterday
saying that there was some
anecdotal evidence of people cancelling
appointments
that's thought to be on the back of some
of the fears
after the stories around the astrazeneca
jab and what's been going on on the
continent but overall he said there was
no
evidence of any significant damage being
done or any significant problem
um with uptake and to re-emphasize that
we obviously had that press conference
last night
with the medicines regulator but also
boris johnson the prime minister will be
getting his
jab he's eligible now because he's in
his 50s today
and he has said he will be having the
oxford astrazeneca job because that's
what they're using
at the vaccination center he's going to
um on supply
actually on that as well whilst it may
be a little bit disheartening for
some younger people such as me maybe who
thought well
checking their phone hopefully over the
next four to five weeks thinking that
you might get an early shout
for a vaccine it now looks likely that
that won't happen that under 50s
will have to wait until may but actually
if you look within the framework of the
timetable
the government has laid out everyone
getting a jab by the end of july
that doesn't seem to impact that too
much and the prime minister and the
government have been pretty clear it
won't
impact the road um out of lockdown i
think what is clear though and what came
from that interview
with oliver dowd and the culture
secretary just then and what's come from
that evidence from warwick university
today as well is that the vaccine
program isn't going to make cobit go
away so even over the summer
there are not going to necessarily be
maskless
free-for-all events at sports stadiums
there may still be a need
for hand sanitizer for one-way systems
for masks
for even covert certificates as well so
a lot of work to do and just because
everyone may have been offered at least
the vaccine by the end of the july
doesn't mean life going back to how it
was before this all started
okay rob thanks very much don't know if
i should admit it but i've had my first
job i'm in that category
thank you let's take a look at the other
stories making the news now this morning
brazil has recorded its second highest
number of daily deaths from coronavirus
official figures show 2724 people died
yesterday
it takes the total number of deaths
there during the pandemic
to more than 287 000
san marino is treating its population
with coronavirus vaccines from
russia the landlocked microstate in
italy has been taking deliveries of the
sputnik
5 vaccines for several weeks the nation
has a deal to buy injections from the eu
but says it's been able to secure the
russia vaccine
much sooner
the white house says it will reach its
target of providing a hundred
million coronavirus vaccines weeks
earlier than planned
president biden says he'll outline new
targets next week
and he's also authorized plans to send
millions of extra jobs to mexico
and canada we will not stop until we
beat this pandemic
next week i'll announce our next goal
to put shots in arms this
is a time for optimism but it's not a
time for relaxation
i need all americans i need all of you
to do your part
teachers and colleges say they're
increasingly concerned about the job
prospects for students taking vocational
qualifications
the pandemic has paused many work
placements and practical lessons have
been disrupted
by recent class closures more than 40
percent of 16 to 18 year olds take a
technical or vocational qualification
laura bunduck has been to the west
midlands to meet the teenagers facing an
uncertain future make sure it's facing
forward
this is as close as they'll get to
flying
holidays on hold but classes continue
the life jacket welcome aboard the
travel and tourism course at hales owen
college near birmingham
students sat down belted up and learning
the ropes
ella's dream is a job on cruise ships i
want to be in this industry
so much like it's um it's really
something i really want to do but the
pandemics pushed back her plans
i might have to be sidetracked to have
to leave college next year but
the path is still there like i'm still
i'm still wanting to do
while i want to go work on cruise ships
so yeah you're determined you will get
there yeah i'm determined i will get
there
there's sharp determination in the
college kitchens
too alice is shaping up her skills
that's it she's training for a job in
hospitality
but facing a jobs market that's anything
but
hospitable it's quite weird now but like
just being hopeful that it'll all come
back to normal soon
everyone's going to want to go back to
eating out and stuff so for like it'll
always be there
there's a different pressure on health
and social care students
their much needed skills make job
prospects
easier it feels rewarding being able to
do a qualification at the
end of it being able to help people
especially those in need
and especially in a sector where people
are needed everyone's
looking at health and social care at the
moment because of how
much they've been helping with the
current situation and
i feel like it has definitely made me
want to go into this
vocational courses are studied by over
40 percent of 16 to 18 year olds
but practical learning and work
placements have been lost
and that's worrying the government it's
also worrying those
awarding the qualifications i think it's
going to be incredibly difficult laura
there's no two ways about it there are
going to be less opportunities out there
for young people
and we've got to continue to invest in
our future talent
so that as the economy recovers as the
labor market recovers we've got work
ready job ready people ready to come
through
that means these students will need to
be prepared
this is an emergency price price getting
careers off the ground
could be a difficult journey laura
bundock sky news
hails owen near birmingham
an education think tank claims it's
found inconsistencies in the levels of
support available to children with
special educational needs in england the
education policy institute says that
access to services
has become what it calls a postcode
lottery
black correspondent ally fortescue joins
us now from
the newsroom and ali and drew us into
some of the detail of
what this this report has found
well they looked at hundreds of
thousands of children in a single
year group over the course of their time
at primary school so they tracked them
for a long period of time and as you say
they show
serious variation inconsistencies
in the level of access for children with
special educational needs but crucially
this was also
about whether children with special
educational needs were even identified
in the first place as needing that
support so children
from more deprived parts of the country
and children that went to academies were
less likely
to access that help were less likely to
be recognized
as needing help and crucially this comes
down to the school so it's not from the
household that the
pupil comes from it's from the school
they go to the place where they
are educated and the education policy
institute
called this a postcode lottery they said
children are falling through the gaps
have a listen to what one of their
directors joe hutchinson had to say to
us a little earlier on
the system for funding of special
educational needs and disabilities is
really
inconsistent and perhaps is not
currently supporting
schools to get this right we need to
have
a conversation between schools and
families
to try to set out what are the sorts of
reasonable adjustments that schools can
make for children with special
educational needs and disabilities
an analysis suggested there were
underlying problems there for children
with special
educational needs and disabilities there
already before the pandemic but this was
exacerbated by the problems we all know
have come for education over the course
of the last 12 months things like
remote learning making it harder for
those children to be
identified and get the help they need
they say the think tanks say
that the government needs to help
provide more help needs to get to grips
with this but
they say for their part the department
for education that they
know despite the important reforms
introduced to
improve support for young people with
special educational
needs and disabilities the system is not
working they say
for every pupil and that's why our send
review is looking at how to make sure
it is consistent all over the country
high quality and integrated
across education health and care the
government they're saying that
effectively
they know there is a problem there they
are doing their best
to try to tackle it i think we get a
very clear
indication here of the real challenges
and the difficulties
that are pretty stark and unfair when it
comes to postcode lottery for children
with special educational needs
ali thank you
let's take a look now at the other
stories making the news for you this
morning
the supreme court is due to give a
ruling later this morning on whether
overnight carers should be paid the
minimum wage for their whole shift
it comes as a care worker campaign to
reverse the decision that carers are
only entitled to payment
when they need to be awake and not while
asleep
official figures show coronavirus has
led to some of the highest ever
television audiences in britain
boris johnson's speech to the nation
announcing the easing of the first
lockdown in may was watched by
27.6 million people the queen's
televised address last april
was seen by just over 24 million viewers
time now to take a look at the weather
for you nas
is that standing by you're smiling again
does that mean
some sunshine sunshine yes and this time
the sunshine looks most likely across
parts of the southeast where it was
really quite dull
yesterday in fact temperatures struggle
to get above six degrees celsius and
chroma
in uh norwich so we are going to be
seeing
higher temperatures more in the way
sunshine there but cloudier
elsewhere
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it is going to be mostly
fine for the rest of
this week but there's going to be a fair
amount of cloud around and it will be a
little wet at times as well in fact for
this morning
it's a murky start with lots of cloud
across eastern parts of scotland
northern england
the midlands central and southern
england down towards the west country
and for most of wales
and quite cloudy too for ireland and
northern ireland but elsewhere there's
some bright or sunny spells developing
particularly across
east anglia and the southeast we'll see
cloud amounts start to
peel back as the northeasterly winds
push through that cloud and there'll be
sunshine and blue skies there but it
will feel quite chilly with those uh
northeasterly
winds elsewhere we hold on to quite a
bit of cloud the patchy light rain and
drizzle
will tend to fizzle away there will be
some brighter sunny spells at times
across ireland and northern ireland too
and for western parts of scotland
there will be a bit of brightness as
well the culture secretary oliver dowden
has told sky news this morning
the government is looking at the
possibility of using covid certificates
to open up sport music and theater
venues from late june
so arenas can return at full capacity
without
social distancing it comes after the
prime minister offered to host more
games in the uk
for the euros tournament this summer
from the 21st of june if
it all goes uh to plan in the way that i
described we hope to get
people back in significant numbers we're
piloting the different things that will
enable that to happen
clearly it will have to be done in a
coveted secure way so you would
expect and we'll be testing these things
things like one-way systems
things like masks things like hand
hygiene and everything else and as part
of that
another thing that we are considering is
a covid certification
and we'll be testing whether we can use
cover certification to help
facilitate the return of sports
an education think tank claims it's
found inconsistencies in the levels of
support available to children with
special educational needs in england
the education policy institute says that
access to services has become
a postcode lottery joining me now is tom
purser from
the national autistic society good
morning to you
and what were your first thoughts about
the findings of this report
well i think the report is really
shocking in that its findings but really
what it does is support what we've been
hearing from families and autistic
children
for years about that massive variability
in
access to support access to assessment
and the different outcomes that autistic
children are having across schools
but why is it happening what in essence
is
is the crux of the the issue
well we know that even before the
pandemic that there were
lots of underlying inequalities
in support at a school level but also at
a local authority level
a lot of variability in approaches from
different local authorities as to how
the support for autistic children was
arranged commissioned and followed
through in schools
and actually it's that level of
inconsistency at a local level both
local authority and
school level that we need to see tackled
and actually there's lots of things that
can be done there that just aren't being
done
what sort of things are you suggesting
well crucially what we need to see from
the government and there's
big opportunities to address this in the
coming year for autistic children
around the scn review and the national
autism strategy
to actually look at ensuring that the
understanding of autism in schools
is raised amongst teaching staff and
pupils themselves
for for every school in the country and
we also need to see
proper commissioning at a local
authority level to make sure that the
the right level and the consistent level
of support
for autistic young people and children
is there
wherever you are in the country to end
this postcode lottery
to make sure that whatever an autistic
child's needs are
every autistic child is different that
they can have a consistent experience
of education wherever they are what has
been your personal experience because
you're the parent of an autistic child
aren't you
yeah that's right um in lots of ways our
story bears out this
issue we've actually had a very positive
experience but actually we have friends
within the same county
who have autistic children who've had
wildly varying degrees of experience
some
positive some very negative depending on
just what part of the county they're in
and what school their child's going to
the willingness to identify assess and
support needs
varies from school to school we've been
very lucky uh but really that's been a
that's been a matter of chance that our
son
was able to get good support but also at
times where
things were difficult um we as
people who've understood the system and
work within it
and have even we've had to fight and
have found it complex
and difficult to navigate and actually
for a lot of families it is
exhausting having to fight the system
to get just an education for their child
and that is absolutely not right
that families should be having to do
that what is it that people
most complain about uh in your circle
that parents
are saying to you that really makes
their life so difficult
well unfortunately it's a real range of
things and it goes right
from the start obviously diagnosis often
follows before educational support in
school
and actually the battle to get a
diagnosis in the first place can take
years the and then when it comes to it
you have to
persuade the local authority in the
school to actually assess
the child whether that's for support in
school or for
education health and care plan and then
even once
that is secured many parents find
themselves having to
fight for the right sort of school for
their child
it might not be in their local area you
have children
going outside of area to be to have
their educational needs met which isn't
always the most appropriate thing
and then eve even at that point actually
getting
the funding there to follow through on
the support that has been established in
a plan
um can still be a huge battle so
unfortunately it goes right throughout
the system and then of course children
change school as well very regularly and
that that fight can start all over again
once they move school
so in all of this also transition
planning from school to school is
extremely
important to maintain that consistency
of support across a child's educational
journey
there's an awful lot to think about um i
wonder what effect
the pandemic and lockdowns have had on
the situation has that
exacerbated uh the problem with with
people trying to access support
yeah the research that the national
autistic society societies carried out
on our left-stranded report
looked at autistic children and adults
experiences during the pandemic and
looking at education in particular we
know that
those underlying inequalities that
existed before the pandemic have been
deepened
um our research showed that um seven out
of ten
uh autistic children found it you know
difficult or impossible to complete
online work and parents about half of
parents said that their children's
um academic progress has suffered um
and 68 of autistic children
said that their um that anxiety is worse
because of that disruption in routine
that they've been experiencing during
the pandemic so lots of
big issues there equally and i think
it's important to recognize that for
some
autistic children there has actually
been a more positive experience during
lockdown with homeschooling coming into
being able to work in a
more predictable controllable
environment at home
but a huge variability around around
that as well some have had a very
negative experience some have had a more
positive experience and actually it's
really important that
what the government do in their sen
review and
in their national autism strategy is
look at all of those experiences and
identify what lessons can be learned
from them
about how the environment in the school
needs change
how teachers need to be trained and
supported
to do what they do in schools and what
local authorities need to be
commissioning at a local level to
give that consistency of support okay
tom person thank you very much i'm sure
people can turn to the national autistic
society
for help also thanks for speaking to us
scientists in ireland have developed
what they believe is the first ever
early warning system to prevent
whales colliding with ships the acoustic
monitoring devices will track the
mammals and send back data on location
in real time
from county cork our island
correspondent stephen murphy reports
a voyage to eavesdrop on a hidden
submarine
soundscape the south coast of ireland is
home to an abundance of whales
including huge fin whales and humpbacks
in the summer
[Music]
but there are also busy shipping lanes
and ship strikes are a significant and
underreported danger to whale
populations
now a new monitoring project could help
this boy launched nine kilometers off
the county court coast
as a smart hydrophone that will listen
in on the area's
many sea mammals in real time
these waters are absolutely teeming with
wildlife so far just on this short trip
we've seen a minky whale
common dolphins and gray seals and the
researchers on this vessel hope that
they can learn new ways to protect these
intelligent species
by using artificial intelligence
the acoustic data will be used to train
machine learning models
to identify different species calls and
ultimately could create a real-time
detection system
we know very little about the rate of
ship strike in irish waters and how
often waves are hit by ships
but we also know very little about you
know how loud our ships are
orca ireland has had an observer's ass
since 2017. so what we hope to do is to
integrate um or acoustics
and detections and the real-time
information coming through into the app
and then that can pop up and it can
notify mariners that there is a
potential whale in the area
so what they can do is they can reduce
their speed and then that will limit the
impact of noise pollution but it will
also reduce the risk of ship strike
apart from the scientific reward derived
from the new technology
mariners here hope the project will help
raise public awareness
what's really important about it is that
and this is something that we do as
boat operators as well is to be aware
that
what we do also affects the animals but
it's to make the general public aware
that these animals are out there number
one but to also respect them when we do
vote or not to disturb them and not to
upset them
this is like um it's one of the good
news stories in the midst of a pandemic
where everything seems to be negative
good news for the whales good news for
the for the wildlife yeah absolutely
from the ocean to the cloud ai and data
analysis could be key
to allow marine mammals and commerce
exist side by side
stephen murphy's sky news off the court
coast
eight people six of them asian women
were killed this week in shootings at
massage parlors in and around atlanta in
georgia
a 21 year old man has been charged with
murder
there are concerns the attacks could
have been racially motivated with hate
crimes against
asian people rising in recent months
how utam is the chair of end the virus
of racism
an organization dedicated to addressing
systemic racism faced by people
of east and southeast asian heritage and
she joins me now good morning to you
um first of all tell us how much of a
problem this issue is
here in this country
thank you jillian it's very common
to think of crimes against east and
southeast asian
heritage people as something that is
happening in the u.s alone but we should
not
kid ourselves that this is also a
problem in the uk
um and the voice of racism has been
tracking
uh has been tracking coveted related
hate crime against
our communities which are obviously
long-standing since the beginning of the
pandemic
and we found that there's been a 300
increase
in hate crimes against east and
southeast asian communities
and these shoot up when lockdown is
eased
we have seen that online there has been
spikes of a
900 global increase in traffic
uh in terms of hashtags that are racist
against east and southeast asian
communities and other
hate crime motivated attacks there
in terms of what we're seeing on the
ground what's less reported is that
migrant workers and you know frontline
workers for example
filipino healthcare workers
disproportionately feature in the death
toll
in terms of uh people affected
in the in the nhs um it's
it's a very raw raw time for a lot of us
you know a lot of us are scared to go
out
every day um and not to mention i think
the daily triggering
of these attacks and seeing the media
response
seeing that um while we've been trying
to raise
the awareness of the issue for months
and months it takes a crisis
to um to get our story
on the news um it's horrendous
uh i'm not surprised that you're you're
a little bit emotional
are you able to tell us some of the the
stories that have been
relayed to you or even your personal
experience
sure um we at end the virus of racism we
work with a network of organizations and
that's one of our key aims is to
mobilize the coalition
of anti-racist and migrant justice
groups as well as east and southeast
asian community organizations
um so some of the stories that we've
heard about are
um assistant sister organizations that
we work with supporting victims of
domestic violence um whether they are
in relationships with their abusers or
they are domestic workers um and a lot
of these
women become undocumented over the
course of
um that they become undocumented
and so they become destitute
as a result of becoming um undocumented
during the process of
uh the treatment um i've already spoken
about
how um the nhs
filipino nationality workers in the nhs
are disproportionately represented in
the death toll
um as well as that we have seen a spate
of hate crime attacks
you know for example just last month um
a lecturer in southampton was attacked
in broad daylight
um and and shouted out calling him
china virus which we know is a rhetoric
that
is been expanded by
donald trump and um it is it is also
something that is latent in terms of
uh the racism that is uh the racism that
is sorry the racism is latent within
british parliament as well as our mp
sarah owen
um has pointed out uh numerous times and
it's not been taken seriously
um as well as that i i myself i'm from a
takeaway background
i have family members who work in the
uh who are domestic workers um and
of course not least of all loss of
income um
and rise in racial abuse but also
um the fear of you know everyday
takeaway
workers they do there's this everyday
racism
um racialized misogyny um
class discrimination that they have
faced you know
and um yeah it's
it's just extremely difficult to see
news of different attacks on these small
businesses
and to know that the uh
while the hate crime incident reporting
is is going up
we're not seeing correspond
corresponding
sort of investment in community building
we're not seeing that these communities
are
being supported or that um everyday
racism in the media
is being called out so it's it's a very
very
um the news over there
affects our communities undoubtedly in
terms of
the the attacks that that you speak of
what sort of support has there been
from the police
um there are
several fora that are set up um with the
met police to talk with
east and southeast asian communities um
and you know and the virus of racism has
been involved in some of these
conversations
one of the first things we did in may
was that we wrote to
the home secretary and the met police uh
demanding accountability for the rising
hate crimes against east and southeast
asian communities
and we have met with the mayor of london
several times as well as hosted
community conversations
um and what we've found is that there is
a lot of willingness to meet
there's a lot of willingness to
allows us to some extent a co-design of
the agenda but in terms of following up
in terms of actual structural change
this is
this is far um leaves much
to be desired um and where with
where we're seeing in the us this crime
being
um this killing being framed as uh it's
it's
it's not racialized hate crime um it's
all because the killer has a sexual
addiction um
this is a severely blind way of looking
looking at the incident when it's clear
that this is
an episode um in a longer standing
history in which race
class um stigma towards
people working in a in a low wage
industry
unprotected workers um and gender
it all intersects together so
it's important to think intersectionally
when we
uh thank you very much for uh sharing
what is a very shocking story with us
this morning
thank you